et se nourrir de façon équitable dans
les années 90 c'était ça puis en bus
mais en 2019
on est rendu là l'équitable est bien
vivant équiterre faisait ya vingt ans
une liste des points de vente de
produits équitables il y avait cinq
points de vente sur la liste on l'a mise
à jour cette liste l'année dernière et
aujourd'hui plus de 800 points de vente
au québec où on peut trouver des
produits équitables
en effet il est plus simple aujourd'hui
de dénicher des produits équitables
surtout qu'on les retrouve aussi dans
les supermarchés c'est intéressant que
les grands distributeurs métro comme
soumise comme l'eau blaze eiffel pas là
de passer à l'équitable
tant mieux pour les producteurs ça ça
fait des gros volumes quand même de
vente pour eux les aliments équitable
sont souvent biologiques mais pas tous
la banane biologique chez métro qui
n'est pas équitable versus la banane
biologique chez iga qui est équitable
elles sont au même prix le cac fait
pareil les cafés bio équitable vont être
dans les même gamme de prix que les
cafés bio non équitable quand vous avez
une certification équitable sur un
produit c'est qu'il ya une transparence
dans la chaîne d'approvisionnement
on sait que les producteurs de ce qu'a
fait de ce thé ont été payés à un juste
prix vous avez également l'assurance que
derrière ça il ya des bonnes conditions
de travail donc pas d' esclavage moderne
pas de travail des enfants
les travailleurs ont des contrats de
travail avec des congés avec le droit à
congé maternité pour les femmes par
exemple c'est vraiment des conditions
sociales dignes et puis en même temps
aussi le respect de l'environnement
en plus du prix juste du prix minimum
quand garanti aux producteurs il ya un
petit montant supplémentaire qui n'est
pas versé aux producteurs mais à la
coopérative pour financer des projets en
santé des projets en éducation des fonds
de pension pour les retraites
certaines certifications nous
garantissent que les produits sont
réellement équitable
le logo qu'on retrouve le plus
facilement chez nous ici au québec et au
canada c'est le logo faire ce choix est
celui qu'on va trouver ici par exemple
sur le thé fort au coq
on le trouve aussi sur le sucre sur le
chocolat sur le café c'est la
certification la plus importante la plus
disponible sur le marché au canada
mais attention fairtrade en un seul mot
photo yd en deux mots c'est la
certification de l'organisme mme
faccioli d'ios et qui ne respectent
aujourd'hui plus les mêmes standards
alors les prix minimums sont plus bas on
a souvent des violations des droits
humains qu'on a constaté sur le terrain
qui n'ont pas été réglés par le système
aussi fatigué de jouer cei va certifier
des grandes plantations et pas seulement
des petits producteurs indépendants
en plus de faire creed en un seul mot
l'association québécoise du commerce
équitable reconnaît la rigueur de ces
deux autres certifications et puis on va
aussi trouver la certification fair for
life qui est beaucoup plus récente
on a ici le symbole des petits
producteurs qu'on trouve chez les café
santropol notamment également chez
camino et james sorkin et jennyfer
lusinski des cafés centre paul sont
permis les premier torréfacteur avoir
faire du café équitable au canada
il fallait appuyer le producteur et non
exploitées les consommateurs qui sont
animés par la possibilité de faire des
gestes au niveau politique avec le
pouvoir d'achat il existe ils ont
toujours existé même si la liste des
produits équitables s'allonge le produit
phare depuis plus de vingt ans demeurent
encore le café la croissance du café
c'est peut-être 2% par an ça suit la
croissance de l'économie mais
l'équitable a augmenté de 18 % l'année
dernière donc on a vraiment des
bottereaux de croissance et qui sont
beaucoup plus rapide que le marché
conventionnel le vin ainsi noté de vins
certifiés équitables j'avoue que c'est
une surprise
alors ça fait quelques années que la saq
offre quelques vins équitable ils sont
pas disponibles dans toutes les
succursales encore mais si vous voulez
demander à votre à votre marchand est ça
qu il va pouvoir les faire venir si les
apports en stock
[Musique]
oh
moi ce qui me ce qui me fait lever le
matin c'est vraiment de me dire que on
peut changer le monde
à chacun de nos achats à chacun des
petits gestes quotidiens qu'on fait
boire un café le matin manger une banane
comme collation
tout ça c'est des petits gestes qu'on
peut faire qui font une grande
différence pour les pour les petits
producteurs
[Musique]